yes we live on the air yes it's great to
be very precise yes thank you just being
live yeah just being on the air alive
right thank you for having me again
thank you for coming it means I was good
last time
or at least decent after what three
times when you go back right 3 times 3
times the decision is made well no good
please don't talk about the weather
alright yeah I'll stay off the weather
yes boring it is boring
have you noticed it's snowing though
yeah no I should get a jacket for it
yeah that's it thank you how are you
Paul I'm good man how are you it's good
to see comedians in the morning it's
very you know I'm not usually at the
cellar yeah we're very dark yeah exactly
how many languages because you you died
oh you did if that you're special now is
called American dream it's a new Netflix
but your first one in English yeah and
you've done it you did a French language
special last year called GAD gone wild
on Netflix how many languages can you
stand up in I I could do four Wow yeah I
could do Hebrew and Arabic have you have
you done yeah I've done comedy in Arabic
and Hebrew but um it was always mixed
like because in Morocco there the second
language is French because Morocco has
been colonized so like many countries in
Africa and North Africa they speak
French so I would mix French and Arabic
yeah and I speak another dialect also is
the dialect that was created by Jews
from Morocco and just created dialects
in Spain created dialect obviously the
Yiddish which is German and Hebrew and
Emeric oh there's another dialect which
is really surprising for those two
people Arabic and Hebrew mixed and it's
dialect that I speak also so I don't
think we counted as a language no but I
mean sure it would be now the dialect is
I mean just knowing the difference man
and I left and I literally have heard of
none of those things right I've heard of
none of I never heard Ebru I've heard of
it I know nothing about any of those
things are you sure
your of course and I am that typical I'm
the typical American ugly in there he
knows Morocco from the road to morocco
movie exactly Casablanca maybe you've
heard of the movie Casablanca yes was
shot in Burbank are you surprised that a
American I was watching the special and
I was kind of surprised I found myself
laughing and American comedy fans
laughing when you would use when you
take dirty words in French like I didn't
even know what the word meant that's
interesting but like when you Kurt I
could tell it was a curse and I was like
oh that's funny he's cursing him French
how many you tell it was just in the way
like in the placement in the sentence oh
yeah
the way he said it like I was like I
understand what this is and it's funny
that he's cursing in a different it's a
terrible one by the way that's why you
felt it the energy maybe it was like a
terrible word in French and I never
curse in French I never do it in English
but this one was so under like from the
heart it's gonna cry nah man that's more
than we [ __ ] but when you own it when
you punch the c kkona good nah like my
French friends would be like what's
wrong with this guy he never talks like
this wait so it's worse than [ __ ] oh
wait is it like is it like the version
of context that like it what it is mmm
no we don't have the equivalent now just
like that this is what as it gets this
is that like the biggest [ __ ] that
you could possibly imagine that's yeah
Kannamma
co and n ard it's a very cultural moment
we're having this morning yes yeah i
like to learn that that's what he wants
to know that if if one did you go to
france we don't know maybe you will go
to france so one day it happens it means
[ __ ] and someone says this right
there jerk [ __ ] all these things that's
how powerful it is yeah we are on the
Jim Norton show that's for sure googling
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and Burke but we did it in your language
what appliance I don't know this is
written here in English that's your
language canard canard no but that's
that's interesting what you said about
the language sometimes I watch comedy in
another language that I don't understand
and I feel it like yeah I know I don't
even when you really saying like like
like merde or whatever I was like yeah
I'm sure if I show okay if I show to Jim
or to Paul some a bit in Russian they
could tell you if the guy is funny all
right
right a little you definitely get the
roar and yeah you comedy in Korea and
say man he's too clean that gets it yeah
they'll say somewhere you've never heard
of it there's like a fingering motion I
got it Russian commedia is like oh this
guy's a one-liner guy Yeah right
so nowhere nowhere in the world can you
put on a Jim Norton special and I have
guys be like oh this is for the family
they know it's garbage they know based
on the head shot it's not for the family
or comedy fans know what's funny about
the language also with Americans is I
find Americans are never surprised right
that we speak their language you guys
come to France
you just go with one little word oh and
we find it cute then you go with the
stupid mercy with a bad accent and we go
oh come this guy speaks almost French no
he's a stupid American who tries a
Frenchie should we just say like hello
and goodbye she would like not even try
no I don't know it's just
you could you could say like oh wow you
speak English I went with my weapon he
can speak a little French him just the
fact that we tried people like were so
appreciative and then they spoke English
to us people play us out
parlez-vous English we have to I think
we have a complex I'm gonna get French
oh yeah the French versus Americans I'm
gonna give you an example there's a
ceremony every year in France it's like
the Oscars but it's smaller and every
year we have look at those big
ters from france big directors they show
up to present a no word or do a speech
or something everyone is clapping and
then suddenly have an American actor he
could be like 23 years old and has done
3 movies and all the room stands up
standing ovations and one day I was
hosting this ceremony and I sat at a
joke as a joke like and this this guy is
yeah he's okay but you just saw a big
actor from France he did 100 movies and
he has a great career he's 80 years old
but there's always something admiration
something intimidating with that do you
think that that's because the
entertainment industry or just in
general because I think like no one
place in America has the army the
entertainment is one thing we do well
yeah yes yeah we've we've got nuclear
weapons and entertainment armies
rightful birthday and marketing and
market market yeah that's all about
marketing I'm sure if we had invented
the hamburger we don't have a good
marketing we have much better food but
our marketing sucks so let me ask you
this you're the biggest comedian in
France and this is no in Europe in
Europe you come to America this is like
a this a country you wanted of course
that's what I mean the conquer right
right now the title of my show it could
sound how you guys say a cheesy American
dream I really feel it this is what I
dreamt of right but now I cannot be I
see these guys at night you know I come
here because I need you know I have to
promote they said that's a good show
your market you know this is marketing
it's a necessity it's not out of love
it's a necessity it's a business
we'll see the feeling we'll see how it
goes no French arrogance no no nobody's
right though we kind of started cocky
and now we're auditioning from hill the
posture look how he's sitting like a
king of course you Jim the xiv actually
I'm
I'm more what I'm doing right now is on
my left hand in my pocket yeah I'm
actually scratching my testicles I'm not
exactly doing that as we talk but you
hole in the in the pocket have you had a
depends with the hole in your pants
cancel the holes on the back Jim Norton
is that an American thing or just a Jim
Norton thing that he tends to touch his
genitals during inter that's a male
thing okay they don't do that in France
and that they do it alone we have a lot
of that's that's funny I was talking to
a comedian a few days ago at the Comedy
Cellar and I said do you think and I'm
gonna ask you this question do you think
it would be easier for a comedian who is
really dirty to become clean or the
opposite dirty it's it's easier for a
clean guy to become dirty than it is for
dirty guy to become clean because a
dirty guy is never avoiding clean stuff
a clean guy is avoiding dirty stuff that
he could write a dirty guy is never
going oh I don't want to write that it's
too clean but you think there's
something there so and you guys tell me
like isn't there i when a clean guy
starts being dirty isn't there something
that just doesn't feel legitimate about
it like this is not how you talk you may
be they usually see them you don't know
that there's no point of reference right
that's why everybody loves Bob Saget's
comedy because they know going in oh
he's gonna be really filthy even though
he's this wholesome family guy it's true
you know he's a good example that but I
think like a lot of guys that like a guy
like Brian Regan who's squeaky-clean and
hilarious if he started swearing it
would be weird I mean they could be
weird for him I think he likes Gaffigan
be clean I heard Gaffigan changed what
he was he was like swear dirty I heard
he's into food now yeah he'd swear
sometimes but there but then he caught
on with a more wholesome audience and
he's just riding it clean there's also
maybe for some ones like I was with Jay
oakerson the other night he was talking
about doing corporates he goes I don't
know man you got to be cleaning those
things I think there's also a confidence
thing like you know with dirty stuff
that that's your that's your sweet
spots so then it's also as the performer
you gotta like change your own internal
sort of cleanest smarter though man
there's so much money oh no I mean it's
a smarter way to go in your career you
can do so many better gigs [ __ ] clean
I would love to not be a pig you know
much more money I'd make you can not
that much no that would be you know you
need jokes - if you don't never see my
faces I really am great documentary two
comedians one clean one dirty by the way
I don't know like the word clean that's
stupid but yeah I was it - gate means
nothing in English clean I'm not clean I
know some clean comedian who are not
cleaning around but let's say two
comedians go on the road one clean one
dirty and they change to try to do like
the opposite may do a one-hour special
at the end of it like 30 minutes each
completely the opposite I like that and
in both specials the audience walks out
but you know what you can't do it I can
do it because they don't know me in
America I would love to try like ten
minutes of very dirty stuff this is to
see why my dad is great dad is saying he
wants do the documentary girls but Jim
you couldn't do it cuz you're to do
you're known but he wants to do it with
somebody else the thing is you cannot
Swit know you can't do it because people
know you that's what I say you can do
the documentary that's almost better if
they tell you it's because it's harder
I'll be ok so I cannot do it freakin so
you could do you and Jim Gaffigan he's
saying he doesn't want to do with you
Jim you got it I am doing it and
Gaffigan wouldn't do with me either
let's do Jim he says six nights at the
Nokia why would he do Maine she doesn't
DC and provide a concept man that's
strong - guy in the tail - Jim's no it's
one Jim in capital letters and then it's
for me to come back six words Jim now
Jim Jim Jim Jim well are you like kind
of under in purpose self-deprecating
high rating yes but also realistic and
Gaffigan who is a lovely man but when
you look at Gaffigan doing you know the
gates he's doing he performed for the
Pope but um also really
I have not o not perform for the Pope
but he wasn't invited
it was so big you use the other names
sometimes no that is true yes I had a
stalker at one point I switched my name
to something are you serious yeah that
was why I was just for stalker
oh so for people who don't know this the
story you can yeah
seem like a bizarre guy just changing
his name yeah you know I just did that
key there was like a legit reason I was
getting okay and now you're becoming
serious yeah and I just was getting
crazy phone calls and stuff I don't want
the club mother okay so I would like to
have these guys I don't have them in
America wasn't a guy Oh better no worse
because I'm weak I'll be if a girl's
crazy even I'm weak really yeah
Wow you see the image I have from this
guy
yeah very in control you see him at the
cellar rolling rocking barely says hi
like hey hey guys this is work somebody
else told me I don't come off as
friendly I'm like I love water friendly
am I really not very great guy but you
know yeah you're a complete canard pause
because we have a callback in French the
science of cold gun art it's my new
favorite word the guy can do a callback
in French it was mark Normand yes I
think I liked him we have Louis not just
him he said all the young comics thought
that Jim hated them but which is so not
true I really like all those guys I love
him I think Joel list is really funny
that's what you said when they're not in
here I'm gonna say no it just seems
always in hurry before but it's he
pretends you know I'm running next door
there's nothing to do over there look at
Jim you go oh man Jim so busy Jim so
busy and then you look at his body of
work and you're like he's not doing
anything I admit that I run home I say I
gotta get home and work on something and
that's something is my deck alone why
make that joke silence and you're gonna
be embarrassed that's what I think of
being dirty it has to be organic right
and true okay that is true I'm gonna try
it go ahead okay if I go home
okay give me the line it was like a home
if I if I say I gotta go home and work
on something I do it's my dick alone
oh so it's it's like I would go out and
be like yeah yeah get like we always see
you around like Ahmed I guess I can I
have funds in Europe and they're gonna
be shocked do this you can't do it okay
if I if I go home we find if I see you
see me yeah and I look like I'm in a
hurry or something I got some stuff to
do means I'm gonna go home and jerk off
no yeah you also didn't do it the way
you would do a regular Joe it's which
because it feels so far and to do it
it's like you're doing it wait like you
know pressure I have to dive down clean
though you have to do clean if you're
doing TV and why did you decide to be
clean from the beginning and same reason
I'm sure he has never decided not to be
it's no we don't do things so you're you
are you're a cleaner I mean I mean I'm
sort of a man you fix it yes yeah
the only thing I started to do a little
bit which is really enjoyable when I
discovered the whole [ __ ] thing like the
word of the activity the sound and it's
like a punctuation it's like if karma
it's like a [ __ ] [ __ ] thing and
and I discovered this but it's stupid
because it's a how you say a crush
thank you can't be yes it can be you
gotta be careful not to use it a lot of
a lot of times ago we want you to work
clean you go what does that mean they go
no f-bombs like that's that's pinnacles
idea of dirties is dropping in the word
[ __ ] and like a lot of times when you
say [ __ ] you're not even talking about
[ __ ] yeah it's really weird but they
college or sometimes you a corporate or
you do like your guys company and you
like dude will let it fly whatever you
want you could be 30 you don't know
you're being taken away in handcuffs
yeah you don't have that's the line they
give you and then you know you're [ __ ]
yes how it works here but when you do
corporates I'm sure it's the same and
then
comes to you before the show and you're
like you can say anything about the boss
you know he's cool he's very fun he's
very funny but don't say this this yes
this don't talk about the company don't
talk about milk don't talk about milk I
see the Hannibal thing you talked about
it yeah about Hannibal guiding a yes his
mic was turned doing a college gig and
when you do college gigs you have to
agree to content so he had signed a
thing saying I want to talk about sex
this ba ba ba and racism you can't even
talk about racism right no but he ended
up immediately going on stage it was a
Catholic University I guess and he
started talking about Catholics and
touching kids and they turned off his
mic immediately and then he started
trying to do the show without a mic and
they turned up background music so there
was nothing he could do eventually they
let him come back on stage and do his
set because people were booing and Bible
but he even showed like he put up on the
screen a picture of what what they told
him he couldn't say you couldn't talk
about ridiculous things like you're
telling me what I can talk about when
you [ __ ] kids like that was his opener
and then they cut the microphone off but
then they let him come back out a few
minutes later yeah yeah I mean it's a
weird thing cuz you are agreeing not to
do it but it's such a ridiculous thing
that they're asking you it's like just
it's supposed to be a free thought thank
you three half the people in that
audience are probably [ __ ] each other
in the office like it's such a sell in
if you talk to them a little bit and
break them down then they'll start sort
of like swearing a little bit and then
it opens the door a little bit to like
but you can't there's all that other
stuff like oh they always tell you don't
do the politics it's too divisive yeah
what about race me yeah right I mean
there's a bunch of conservatives in
there but but great comics we don't have
this in Europe it's not censored it's
not never bleep never that but it
created here great comics in the history
of the comedy here in the United States
it created that pressure created George
Carlin you know yeah so I like his old
stuff better when he was cleaning a
comedy team but I'm in the minority
there okay if you like the dirty
language you know before the hippy hippy
no weatherman
I like that with the money we did
ponytail I like I like Ed Sullivan Pryor
that's just like the dirtier stuff yeah
do you like do you like the when you're
here nobody you know the general public
doesn't necessarily know how famous or
rich or any of that stuff you are
looking kind of skirt under the radar
for the moment anyway hatin um I love
that because it's very rare when people
come to me and talk like last night I
was in a club and comedy club I don't go
to clubs and by the way that was very
surprising she said to me this lady she
said oh I heard the story on NPR This
American Life and I was like how could
she recognized me from radio show that's
weird
but because radio as you know we're
doing it right now it's now almost more
than TV you know it's like party oh yeah
radio and podcast it's called your name
back in the day she knew your name right
yeah my name and she stole my set and
then she talked to me I was so you know
in France or in Europe they come up to
me and they talk to me and I'm like I
mean her I'm like this guy at this hour
you know I gotta go home and jerk off
I've got stuff to do and what's funny
here I take time I'm like it sometimes
I'm like it's you in a picture just give
me back my money it's just it's really
enjoyable I love it you know it's you
talk to people I don't get recognized so
I got the good sides going onstage and
do the job I love and I don't get you
know have you bother when you have any
of the young comics like said anything
stupid to you because they don't know
who you are any other head you're just
going like you [ __ ] know but they
know everyone knows you know the funny
thing is the first night like two three
years ago I did a set at the Comedy
Cellar I was just moving here to New
York and a big beautiful apartment in
Tribeca in New York City just moved from
friends and I took three four comedians
for a drink I say come over you know you
guys don't do this we do it a lot in
Europe you don't invite people to your
house yeah do you don't do some people
you still have it invited
I said come over guys and I was a guide
for them in their head just comedian
like them who just made like 100 bucks
at the comedy Center and we walk into
this apartment and they were kind of
scared like I was a drug dealer with the
view and everything this is like that
though you might like I got an erection
I say this only on that show and then
that's why that's that's that's for you
now if you said hard-on instead of a
record yeah she kept it medical so you
bring them up they see this at what
floor you want how high up seventh floor
so you have a nice view friend in New
York of course how many bedroom I worked
hard how many bedrooms three that's big
no that's not big Tribeca that's big
5,000 top you know you have three big
how many three but made it to two
Wow how come how can you make it to do
as a murder they're smaller you knock
the wall down this dick do you know the
word boner do you ever say boner I know
I like I like the sound are you saying
boner such a sophisticated voice in such
a silly word means happiness no the same
thing here you've never heard me never
now are these your publicists Carole
works with me she's my right hand okay
so blow jobs and I never talk like that
she's gonna get married in a few months
I apologize to her man and I'm not
invited because you know what she gives
me the best reason in our respect she
said because it's gonna be in South of
France she's doing this wedding within
the village you know where she's born
she said if you come to the wedding they
gone you're gonna be the center cause
you're gonna be asking everybody if they
want to take a picture with it yeah
she's know I'm gonna steal the show she
thinks okay you know what's interesting
I had that concern about Jim and I
invited him to my wedding not an issue
so Carol is not a publicist allies the
publicist and they're my team so have a
big entourage so now you you know you do
you work with other people are just get
so you're not inviting him though
maybe manager won't invite it because
they invite one client they have to
invite all the clauses like if they they
have to James for example yes I can get
the invite regarding would get the okay
so the South of France you you do I know
st story I've never seen who live there
I've seen the seller a million times but
st went and she's like he's doing like
twelve thousand seat arena yeah two
nights and she said you do a great show
it's like it's a long set it's you know
two hours yeah yeah it's a bit though
the show she saw was a big show with the
that's funny because we called those
shows and friends are American like the
American Way and it's not American at
all but stand-up comedians here and I
learned that from you guys how to be
very so simple like really it's an
economic thing I guess I thought it was
more of philosophy but no screens no
dancers no yeah the screen is okay just
for people I mean my kids don't require
one no need to be first screen you're
not get a DC improv no no I'm actually
bigger than what's on the screen it's
not necessary the screen that jim has
for his show it's one of those TVs that
they used to use in like school when it
was movie day they just one thing I find
really I don't know stupid or ridiculous
or surprising is one comedians I'm sorry
guys if you do it right their names on
the backdrop in in a big huge letter so
we don't have this in Europe so mmm I
don't know why they do this I act
I do that but I don't put just my name I
put that forever you are enjoying Chris
Rock did CR I mean he does CR a lot oh
yeah Dave Chappelle like puts a big see
on the stage he's got your pal I would
too if I had that name would you want to
put Norton all over the place no no no
yeah I broke you big in Frank was there
like it was a movie yeah I played a
transvestite there pretty woman did you
yeah I played a woman what movie
shoo-shoo it's called Shu Shu I was just
as a woman and and and and acted as a
woman google it and see the face right
into your apartment he wants to go to
your apartment place but not for us Elsa
likes I like saying it transvestite
everything wrong
it's ch oh you see Hou Co show show show
is like a Chinese chambers died oh don't
worry about Troy he also can't spell in
English so it's not a language barrier
thing yeah shoo shoo it was a big big
hit during friends what year 2003 2003
thank you that's a guy oh yeah yeah I
kissed a guy boner
yeah is it a bad word no no that show
comedians in cars Jim no Jerry's never
asked me to dress you because you to
know you're too dirty Jerry doesn't mind
dirty comics see he just doesn't do it
himself
yeah we know each eye I would not fry no
Seinfeld we're not friends we're not we
just know what you looking the same yeah
they like bleep the swears like when
Sarah Silverman was on they believed her
a bunch of times so I think is your
dirty no right no because why would you
want to be in a car with Jim okay
like coffee I love coffee are you I
enjoy you get carsick you get carsick
he's not worried about that coffee sick
yeah you take a car to work every day
yes I do
so what would be the only well it's just
been a long list of people had a lot of
great comedians on there like Alec
Baldwin and Christoph Waltz episodes
with Jim Gaffigan that's right Jim
Nabors talk shows in America on talk
shows sure but the problem is is not a
reciprocated life like you're I'm moved
by you to this morning I'm I see this
man very offensive dirty swearing
cursing yelling at the crowd every night
and I see here a little boy totally
broken right now that's like that's the
kid next to me what are you gonna do
today Jim with all the schools closed
what does how does that change your
afternoon sure sure anything say
anything you want see what happens
you know what happened before I walked
into this room I never asked a picture
to a celebrity never I don't I don't but
there was the mayor of New York oh do
you see him I asked for a picture what'd
he say they said yes of course and he I
I said I just moved to New York I want
to you know I want a picture with the
man who's in charge of this you are I'm
gonna be living in so we took a picture
and I'm gonna post it I was you know
although I'd be careful when you post it
cuz a lot of New Yorkers hate that guy
everybody in New York I'm gonna ask you
something guys
please try any of you suggest a caption
for this picture I hate this man about
to be beaten by Cynthia Nixon no I'm
thinking of it the governor yes
okay I'm not from here but I get it it
looks like how about check out this
canard so I'm thinking about all day
that's my new word I would keep it light
um this is the mayor of New York feel
how you I just wanted to say hi how can
i linked without being obvious like my
special on Netflix and the mayor of New
York the whole how about this um I have
a special on Netflix this is the mayor
if you don't like either of these things
kill yourself just something like that
tell yourself or go watch Jim Norton
right the bad people would say that's
the same thing no I would say watch my
special I promise this man's name won't
come up because you don't mention him in
you know he's not a dream mayor I still
honey you want to get why don't you put
I push this man onto the subway tracks
Giuliani was very well-liked right after
9/11 like in 2001 yeah well kind of like
him because he's a good mayor he cleaned
up the year he's actually a really good
job in New York
he's more well-liked the prosecutor like
a Giuliani photo would go over better
than a de Blasio yeah a Bloomberg or we
go home at Koch and they died you know
you should maybe it could create a
little you know debate no chatter and
Americans could you know be like about
this if you don't like this guy you're a
[ __ ] ass well how about this you go
I'm so happy to be in America and I was
honored to meet your president how about
random people in New York asked me for a
picture all right I can't say no or yeah
here's what you do and here's how you
tied in met this fan saw me on Netflix
loved me
this is picture with anybody
[Laughter]
yeah but he won he was a now because I
look like he WL mondo del mundo de el
mundo Belmondo the son of John Barry
mundo look at this guy oh my god good
call the picture of him with this
cigarette in his mouth there look just
put that hat on him that's like the
handsome version Wow big celebrity
actually a big French celebrity biggest
Wow is he so life yes do you know him
yeah he got an a stroke so he can thanks
that makes me feel good no he's very
he's very well you really look like him
like look at the [ __ ] you know go back
Jim can you can you can you name one one
French actor okay come on you're a DEP I
do I know you are you guys oh what about
the guy from man
the guy for a Berto paninis not French
oh my god I can say irreversible right
what about Eve's mom Tong Wow what about
a Michael Caine French Oh can you
imagine who's the dude in Casablanca
that plays the cop what's is no Humphrey
Bogart Humphrey both French I don't know
Rizzo Rose McGowan Leo DiCaprio yeah I
fire that Gerard before anybody else you
know you nail that one we don't know a
lot of French actors I guess could they
do movies I don't know
no because you're not curious about
nothing you don't give a [ __ ]
no no I would watch a good French movie
though oh wait I can I can give you one
more pair Vanessa
oh yeah hurry as I said no no uh good
yeah she wasn't married to Johnny Depp
and she why that's the link she married
my horror music now what's her name
Vanessa Adi wait a minute
wobbly yeah yeah but something name of
the character family what was your name
Audrey - Audrey I know you gotta give it
- I didn't mind if I do
rom-com with her really yeah it's called
priceless me and Audrey toe - you think
the whole movie if I were you dressed as
a woman
sorry well you know what did you fall in
love with her a little bit why she's
cute no I fell in love we'd Sophie mocks
ooh oh she's hair like Adrienne Barbeau
though some of those pictures are the
old oh great Sophie most so Sophie
Matsui zoom so beautiful yes Gibbs look
at Sophie Marceau how old Detroit could
you just write Sofia songs oh yes he'll
be Marcel myself - [ __ ] just write em
AR see ya you yeah mmm you know close
missus yeah wow she's pretty very lovely
oh she's nice big feet nice feet let me
to scream that are you into
feet I like big size 9/10 they're smooth
they have to be nice feet they can't be
bunny bun you need it to be really nice
what is bunny you need it was like just
a mess they can't be all callous could
the paws is weird up there she's very
Freddie the food there
she's made movie she's in the David
Spade movie where he takes her dog and
pretends to bring it back to her that's
a good plot I tried what did she I mean
I was I was shooting a movie with her
every day we would kiss and and fall in
love in the movie and at night I would
go home like Jim Norton home her trailer
alone and you know and cherkov out yeah
look out the window of your nice
apartment ago no one to share it with
it's a beautiful apartment nice apart
thank you Sam yeah I'm one of the few
that have seen the inside but yes you
want so I get one of the few that's made
it out one window open who said who said
that comedians sitting together are not
funny I think it's funny I don't know
Colin even in France what is this thing
this exasperation [ __ ] parrot wrong
Frankie gets too close look at us a
bunch of I don't know guys sitting bunch
of men man maybe with an asterisk right
yeah watching pictures of hot women who
else have you made out with that we can
look up I would like to know that
who else yeah you're very very famous
there so you probably date a higher
level of person than we do it because
you you know you played it famous people
is that tough to come to America and is
it a little bit more difficult to get
celebrities to date you of course I'm
not even celebrities women
in Europe come on I'm not because it
easy no the good thing is you can get
you can go on a dating app in America
and nobody knows you that's the best in
France I can't because you know right
that'd be great you get the pick of the
litter he says he puts his headshot on
him with his name no it's it's so
different you know it's the network and
also and also the the whole dating thing
here and the flirting thing it these
days is weird here in America yeah but
I've seen him with women before and they
literally they were women that I'm like
oh my god that's the type of person I've
just seen on a magazine it was
humiliating for me as another male to
realize that I'll never date a woman
like that so I walked down the stairs
pretty girl yeah but I don't if they
knew what you do and you can do in that
apartment I'm sure that would come to
you right away
yeah defeat norton dating stories one
time he went on a dating app yeah and he
meant like a young girl on his dating
here and she invited him over to her
place and he was like oh that's great
news right and so he goes over to her
place and he gets there and she's
hanging out with another girl even
better sounds great and then he finds
out that as a joke they made it they're
inviting over another guy from tinder oh
yeah I don't know I didn't meet him on
tinder I've been her in person
oh so I go to her place I'm hanging out
with her and a girlfriend and she goes
that's a joke we just invited this
tinder guy over and I'm like really
she's really kidding so I'm saying they
thought of you not me him me actually
she do you think this is funny so the
guy comes over and then it's four of us
and almost said the other girlfriend
goes home so it's me and this guy seeing
who get out [ __ ] block each other so I
said you know what I played it smart
though I'm like you know what I'm gonna
go you guys have a great night and I
left and a few minutes later she why did
you leave I was just trying to be funny
of a blah blah blah and then I wound up
the guy left and then I wound up going
back and having oral sex
[Laughter]
I don't know it's dating I don't know
it's wrong don't what I do I I don't go
on dates I'm I'm afraid of being bored
so I just [ __ ] no I think I say come
come swing by the the comedy clubs I'm
gonna be in that Club so I have comedy
all the time right I cannot go do you
want to go on a date you want to go for
three hours and arrest I'm married yes I
love a good dinner you do I love dinner
no I'm a good dinner
I saw you in Montreal I'm a good dinner
in Montreux like nice master and he's
looking for the nice good food and no
yeah I'm a gentleman one minute I
thought you would a bountiful girl in
much